the Joe Rogan experience you know you
have a very unusual perspective for
someone who makes their living as an
actor what do you mean why do you think
so you're very thoughtful person a very
thoughtful I know I know a lot of thank
you - I do - yeah but it's not common
you got to find them you got to curate
those folks yeah I am
it's a funny
it's a funny it's a funny gig by like by
definition it's like if you think about
all the like the yin yang and it the
paradoxes in it it's like on the one
hand with guys this actors there will be
a lot of um you know there's a certain
kind of uh not macho but there's like
you know men will look to play intense
roles and write these things but what
you're doing is like it's it's you're
playing dress-up
like you know you're you're like and I
always like I was like the Dorothy
Parker the famous New York you know
writer said scratch an actor you'll find
an actress I think it's the great it's
line it's not and it's not how it sounds
just to be a little you know like if
that's not a knock on actresses no no
more if I mean but that's the real truth
of the whole thing is like we put on
makeup we put on clothes we play dress
up and we pretend to be other people and
it's like it really is like you know
when people are like you know sometimes
you my brother and sister will laugh
because I've done these certain things
that have a certain kind of iconic
intensity or whatever right like you and
they look at me and they're like are you
kidding like you've seen the size of his
ankles here they're like my brother's
just like he's such a twerp like he's
that job he's my brother's like two
inches bigger than me and 30 pounds
bigger and way stronger you know my
little brother and he's and it's always
like he is that he's a theater nerd he's
not like tough they're like don't you
play the Hulk
ya know but um or American history
history I do but I do I do think there's
there's sometimes there's a it's really
funny the way there's a posture and it's
um
times there's like a pot there's like a
public-facing posture that some people
who are in this trade this weird thing
will adopt and it's like it's like hey
man I hate to tell you but like like you
don't have to live in to some you don't
have to live in the it I sometimes feel
like people are compensating for the
fact that what they do in fact is play
dress-up right do you do you think it's
also that they have to kind of project
this image to ensure that they get more
of these tough guy roles or maybe maybe
I don't know I don't know I think um or
or maybe it's like that's who they
wanted to be maybe in a weird way
they're living in to some some people I
think they they relish the opportunity
to change the story of who they are you
know what I mean they're they're they're
they're getting to through through
getting well-known they're getting this
chance to sort of like wipe the slate
you know of whatever it is they were
getting away from and they're getting to
you know the chance to sort of create a
create a persona that they're they're
happier with them then what then before
you know right look what they wish they
always were yeah
[Applause]